whether you play the game or not you're
probably aware that cs go skins are
worth a lot of money the reality is it's
now a billion dollar industry with
record sales happening every single year
but all of this money has attracted
ripoff artists who are preying on those
who don't know the value of their own
skins and they're making an absolute
[ __ ] turn off them everyone knows about
these sharks but for reasons we're about
to get into it's not that easy to stop
them
[Music]
where would you look at the time it's
that time of the video where i asked you
guys to subscribe to the channel if you
enjoyed this video also leave a like and
hit the notification bell look i
wouldn't tell you to do it if it wasn't
worth it
you gotta trust me i'm a random guy on
the internet now admittedly i'm not the
biggest cs go guy on the channel i think
you know the name of the the actual
person but the skin world in cs go has
always fascinated me especially the
darker side of it so in order to tell
this story properly i spoke to some of
the game's premier skin experts they
guided me through this whole underworld
and even put me in touch with a victim
of it we're gonna get pretty into the
weeds in this video so i think it's
probably best if we quickly run through
the basics now skins are texture
cosmetics for weapons like a lot of
games they can be purchased in the form
of crates which you then unbox for a
random skin these crates can also be
rewarded as random drops for playing
games or for watching professional
matches now where csgo differs from
other games and it's a pretty big one is
that skins are tradable every skin is
obtainable if you've got the real life
cache to cough up for it this feature
was first implemented in 2013 as part of
csgo's arms deal update which gave
players access to 100 weapon skins and
in just two short years the player base
grew more than 13 times over from 25 000
average players when the arms deal
update was released to over 357 000
players by august 20th 2015. now this
wasn't a coincidence it was skins i
don't think it's an exaggeration to say
that skins kinda saved csgo at a time
when its future did not look that
certain and i don't think i need to
explain to you why csgo skins became so
popular they look cool you can pick up
an opponent's weapon and kill them with
their own skin they're a status symbol
you know why they're sick but their
insane popularity has led to a skins
economy that has exploded over the years
a cs go weapons case for instance was
worth about 30 cents in 2013. in june
2021 it reached just under 60 dollars
that's almost a 20 000
increase in recent years skins have even
begun to sell for over a hundred
thousand us dollars the point is this
[ __ ] is massive and it's only getting
bigger but like flies to a pile of [ __ ]
the big money has also attracted sharks
who are looking to make a quick book of
people who don't know the true value of
a skin they own they offer naive traders
a low amount and then flip the weapon
for a large profit now obviously it's
easy to just blame all of this on bad
people but this may have all started the
moment the valve began designing rare
skins i spoke to csgo content creator
jesus who explained to me just how the
creation of skins may have led to the
ripping off we're seeing today it comes
back to the way valve design skins they
actually design skin specifically with
um
rare patterns and stuff like this in
mind i don't think they anticipated them
being worth tens of thousands of dollars
but
when they were designed and the the
woman who designed skins has spoken
about this they wanted to have obscure
rare patterns that was a big deal to
them they wanted to promote like this
trading ecosystem and have like
different different avenues by which
schemes could be valued and one of the
one of the ways they really pushed that
was with in particular the case hardness
which is what zippo was talking about
and where a lot of this scamming happens
uh they deliberately tried to create
this market for observed case hardened
patterns
but because it's been just this wildly
successful popular thing that they
didn't anticipate with padding's worth
you know anything from 1 000 to 1.5
million dollars it's created this huge
spectrum for what is essentially you
know industrial scale fraud to take
place by a few sort of dodgy individuals
and these dodgy individuals troll
through skinned databases looking to see
who's opened a particularly rare case
hardened item like a blue gem for those
of you that don't know a blue gem is the
name given to a randomly determined
pattern on a case hardened skin that has
a predominantly blue color on one side
they are extremely sought after and so
extremely valuable ranging from a few
thousand dollars to estimates of over
one million for the likes of a famous
case hardened blue gem karambit and
that's not the only factor that
determines the value of a cs go weapon
if it has stat track which tracks the
total number of kills the owner has made
with the weapon that increases the value
the grade of a weapon can greatly affect
the price ranging from common to
contraband and then of course stickers
can up the value even more the thing is
the average cs go player doesn't really
know that much about the value of rare
skins the database prices are usually
inaccurate and the specific skin-to-skin
differences that pump up the value often
require a trained eye to spot and that
is when the sharks pounce they approach
the owner of a rare skin and offer what
seems like a good price either with real
money or with other skins that aren't
worth as much as they say they are and
the problem with this kind of thing is
that it exists in a kind of gray area
they aren't hacking anyone's account or
stealing their skins they're making a
trade offer which the owner can simply
decline thoroughly speaking this is
obviously pretty messed up innocent
people are getting ripped off jesus
explained to me that unfortunately this
may just be a symptom of the skins
market in its current form the nature of
the market really allows unscrupulous
actors to really exploit just a lack of
information about what the true price of
certain items are and many people
certain individuals into essentially
giving up tens of thousands of dollars
on a trade it's so
the issue is more sort of the opaqueness
of the market and the way that can be
exploited by people who have just
objectively
bad intentions
i also spoke to zippl a well-known
content creator and skins expert and
during our conversation one name kept
coming up as an alleged shark a trader
named toucav now zipple put me in touch
with sam a young cs go player who had
been approached by two cav after he
opened up a weapons case with a stat
track blue gem ak inside now at first he
didn't even know it was a blue gem he
was just happy to get the ak skin that
he wanted it was a valuable skin and it
didn't take long for trade offers to
start coming in from those who have been
scouring the database sam then
approached zipple to see if he was
interested in buying the ak as part of
their discussion sam said that zipple
had a valuation done on the gun by a
friend and the results came back between
12 and
thousand dollars that information was
then passed on to sam it was then that
sam started getting messages from two
cav who was extremely persistent with
his offers but after consulting zipple
sam knew the offers were too low
he was the one that was sharking me
non-stop i remember he was sending me uh
trade requests like none like every
every like two weeks every now every
week yeah every week he'd be like oh
i'll give you this for that and then
there was a point where i was talking to
zippo and then he was like oh i'll give
you 6k for it uh paypal and i was like i
don't know if i really want to do that
when sam told zippel about the offers he
was shocked for him it didn't add up at
all so you can see here that two cars
sends an offer here for a hydroponic ak
a huntsman sapphire huntsman sapphire
and huntsman ruby all these items amount
to
around 3k dollars and then on the other
side you have the 12 000 ak where he's
also asking for his m9 slaughter and his
gloves so this is like a typical one
where you know as i said two cavs would
then probably ask well you can just send
it without your combo and then hope that
he will accept it but because of the
fact that he got help from someone that
is not trying to take advantage of him
then he uh you know
he he didn't do it it took a while but
the pushy offers stopped sam told me
that he knew two cam's intention was to
flip the ak for much more than he was
being offered with the help of zipple
sam ended up selling his ak to a
legitimate trader for ten thousand
dollars a much more reasonable price
these sorts of sharks can target anyone
who opens a case and gets their hands on
a rare skin but quite often you hear
that the victims that fall prey to this
have one thing in common they're pretty
young they may feel pressured by the
sharks to give up their skins cheaply
and quickly because hey they're an adult
the sharks take advantage of that power
dynamic to get what they want and what's
more is that even sharks are getting
shocked zipper told me that in his
experience sharks are getting preyed on
by even bigger sharks who flip the
weapons for even bigger profits before
they themselves are preyed on by even
bigger sharks
if that makes sense an item that was
originally sold for a few thousand
dollars can then pass up the chain to
the top of the ladder where the biggest
sharks are making tens of thousands of
dollars in profit so
what can we do about this well as
someone who is approached by an alleged
shark sam doesn't really hold out too
much hope for change
i don't think it can be fixed
because
well
there's always people gonna be out there
to like go and say oh i want this
because it's just people being pushy
it's
it's not something the steam market
could fix
if they wanted to fix that well i mean
then
it's not possible no like they can't
don't get it wrong this stuff isn't
right by most people's standards these
sharks will distort manipulate and lie
to get what they want but at the moment
there's no rule against making pushy
trade offers there's no rule against
making a shitty offer in many ways valve
has been like an absentee parent through
all of this they created cs go skins
which then burst a thriving economy but
now they're reluctant to step in and try
and stop the rampant rip-offs that are
taking place and it can be hard to
detect a shark because of this some of
them will make an offer that isn't
totally insane but is a blatant rip-off
to a trained eye that way if they ever
get accused of being a shark they can
just say there was a difference in
valuation the less intelligent and
greedy sharks will massively undervalue
a seller's item in order to maximize
profit but this also makes them
extremely detectable to the community
and this is what jesus was alluding to
earlier in the video the opaqueness of
the market is a big problem here as long
as people are uninformed about the true
price of their skins and databases don't
help them either there will always be
more knowledgeable people looking to rip
them off i asked sam if he had any
advice for people who are looking to
trade their skins and he simply said
patience if you think you have something
valuable on your hands you need to just
sit tight and wait for as many offers to
come through so that you can figure out
what the true value of it is sharks will
be quick to make offers gambling that
you don't know any better in the
beginning i think one of the greatest
tools to have against sharks is to have
knowledge of them hopefully this video
has helped you with that and if your
next skin is worth twenty thousand
dollars you won't rush into anything too
quickly
well this is one of those moments where
everyone freaks out because i'm not
about to say premiere
here we go
oh i'll put you in prof oh you got after
the prep yeah well i didn't say that did
i just say premiere i just said premiere
oh go go go go